مشاهدينا اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي رصد
عمليه اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع غزه صوب
مستوطنات الغلاف ما ادى الى تفعيل صافره
الانذار في المستوطنات المحيطه بها ومن
جهتها قالت مصادر محليه في قطاع غزه ان
الفصائل الفلسطينيه اطلقت الصاروخين من
نوع 107 اتجاه موقع عسكري اسرائيلي في
مستوطنات غلاف غزه وذلك بعد ان رفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي حاله التاهب الى القصوى بعد
عمليه عسكريه ادت الى مقتل سته فلسطينيين
بينهم ينفذ عمليه حواره التي اسفرت عن
مقتل مستوطنين وهذه الصوره المباشره
مشاهدينا من غزه بعد اطلاق صاروخ من
القطاع باتجاه مستوطنات اسرائيليه هذه
الصور مباشره مشاهدينا كما ذكرنا من قطاع
غزه بعد الحديث عن اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع
باتجاه اسرائيليه اطلقت فيها ايضا صافرات
الانذار كل ذلك مشاهدينا ياتي في وسط
التوتر الذي نجم بعد اقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه لقريه حوار يوم امس وقتلها
سته فلسطينيين بينهم
ينفذ العمليه التي نفذت داخل المناطق
الاسرائيليه واسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنهم نذكر
مشاهدينا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن رصد
عمليه اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع غزه صورته الان
بشكل مباشر صوب مستوطنات الغلاف ما ادى
الى تفعيل صافرات الانذار في المستوطنات
المحيطه بها مصادر ايضا محليه مشاهدينا في
قطاع غزه اكدت ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
اطلقت صاروخين من نوع 107 اتجاه موقع
عسكري اسرائيلي في مستوطنه غلاف غزه وكل
ذلك مشاهدينا ياتي بعد ان رفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي حاله التاهب الى القصوى بعد
عمليه عسكريه ادت الى مقتل سته فلسطينيين
بينهم منفذ عمليه حواره التي اسفرت عن
مقتل مستوطنين